avant de partir en tunisie vous avez
fait là la rencontre de la belle série
dans la grande race régate on se
rappelle ici vous avez semblé bien
accrocher tous les deux et d'ailleurs au
départ c'était aussi pour cela qu'on
partait en tunisie ouais ouais je vous
avais réussi à tenir vos engagements
ce que vous allez aller au bout avec
cyrine vous allez voir ce soir lille de
la tentacule
[Rires]
et ce qui se passait
maxime merci d'être venu assister aux
vaccinations après maxime tu connais ma
droiture
tu connais ma fidélité
tu connais mon dégoût pour le mal et
maxime j'ai vu des choses qui m'ont
beaucoup aidé maxime ces choses
je ne peux pas les garder pour moi
malheureusement et toutes ces choses
sont ici
c'est passé loin c'est vraiment très
grave je pense que tu sais ce que tu as
fait maxime est ce que sérine peut venir
nous rejoindre
[Musique]
salut salut bonsoir cyril pas ils ont en
effet accepté de faire un bout de chemin
ensemble
les sentiments sont réciproques toujours
le bienvenu en tunisie syrine vous êtes
magnifique vous avez encore le sourire
oui combien de temps
syrine
il est devenu sous cette île de la
tentacule avec maxime pour tester vos
sentiments votre amour maxime c'est un
garçon sérieux ont considéré comme un
garçon sérieux oui complètement
je le suis malheureusement sur cette île
de la tentacule maxime
n'a peut-être pas eu un comportement
irréprochable
j'ai ici des images
si line
est ce que vous voulez voir les images
ah oui on est vraiment sûr
ce que vous voulez voir les images oui
voulait dire on va voir les images
oui oui forcément nécessaire vous m'avez
voir les images non dopé
vous voulez voir les images oui vous
voulez donc que je projette les images
sur cet écran quand vous voulez les voir
oui oui série lh je te confirme je veux
voir les images qu'est ce que vous
voulez voir les images
ma question aller simple elle est claire
elle est précise
c'est une question
qui termine un point d'interrogation
vous voulez voir les images puis si je
vous résume h
et je vais vous montrer des images votre
amour il y à hammamet
j'espère qu'il ne va pas se terminer à
tozeur
ce que voulaient voir maintenant les
images tout à fait je vais les voir
maintenant prêt serait pas tombé une
semaine on
maintenant vous allez voir les images
oui maintenant oui
[Musique]
selon michel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je peux pas je peux pas continuer à voir
sa gamme de danseurs ce qu'on voulait
revoir les images
non merci ça fait vraiment que la
confiance s'est présenté à toute ma
famille j'en reviens pas c'est juste une
histoire de non non non non je prenais
la danse sur glace se fait tu m'a foutu
vraiment leur chemin
mais toi devant toute la france
sirène messi
ce que voulait repartir
ensemble
ou séparément de l'île de la tentation
[Musique]
mais franchement c'était un chrono donc
sacs jaunes ya un nom des données non tu
m'a vraiment manqué de respect je lui
réponds non désolé décidé donc ça se
décide à moi j'aimerais bien l'ascension
mais pour ces mais il faut être deux
ouais ça chauffe si rien je vous
demander de reprendre votre chemin et
maxime de reprendre le vôtre pour
participe à rémy c'est pas la folie
[Musique]
n'est pas revoir les images
et
ils sont sympas les images